family blood is a 2018 Blum House horror
film the director Netflix movie centers
around a single mother dealing with
their transformation into a vampire
avoiding the usual jump-scare centric
motif that Blum Howser known for this
movie thematically tries to study
addiction under a horror premise
throughout this video I will be
discussing the film's plot and ending as
well as some of the main conceptual
ideas that it tries to tackle there will
be huge spoilers throughout this video
so make sure you avoid this for now if
you're looking to check out the film
with fresh eyes without the way I'm
definition and this is my ending
explanation of family blood the film
opens on Christopher the movie's main
antagonist and vampire slaughtering a
family
Christopher attempts to control his
addiction and let Kristin the daughter
escaped but when the Bloodless gets the
better of him
he too adds her to the body count from
here we join Ellie and her family Ellie
is a recovering drug addict that once
was heavily under the influence of an
unnamed pill thus addiction ruined her
family and has led to her children
having a troubled childhood that means
they find it difficult fitting in and
conforming to the rules during an
addicts meeting Ellie is joined by
Christopher he fits in well because like
the addicts his efforts to control his
vampirism often fail and his demons
regularly get the better of him we see
this come to fruition when he kills a
drug dealer and forces Ellie to become a
monster like he is after this Ali begins
to exhibit signs that her body is
transforming into a creature of the
night
she rapidly heals from wounds and is
unable to stomach anything other than
blood her addiction is shown to grow
monstrously when she digs through the
trash in order to find a blood-soaked
napkin to eat and after this encounter
Christopher informs her that there is
nothing that she can do to help
change her bloodlust comes to a head
when she murders a neighbor and her cat
his son Kyle discovers this and realizes
what is happening
Christopher puts doubt in Kyle's mind
when he tells him that he cares about
hailey and that he did it to stop her
from taking pills he reiterates that she
now has a new addiction but like all
addictions it can be managed and
therefore Ali will not ruin her family
like she did when she was a slave to the
pills Elly and Christopher begin a
murder spree that culminates in Kyle
attempting to kill elite vampire once
and for all
failing to drive a stake through his
heart le Leapster Kyle side and as a
team they managed to stop Christopher by
stabbing him with a stake repeatedly
from this Kyle vows never to leave le
side but once again the addiction
becomes too much and le attempts to
murder him both children violently fight
their mother and are left on the brink
of death while defending themselves
Ellie flees into the night leaving them
behind and that the film's closed we see
Ali going under a fake name attending a
new 12-step program personally I would
like to take this as a positive note
that she is trying to control her
addiction however it is most likely that
she is operating in a similar fashion
that Christopher had and her next victim
isn't too far away family blood is
obviously heavily scented around
addiction and wiles elements of it are
in the supernatural there are several
aspects of addiction based in reality
that we see throughout the film the most
obvious is the fact that Ali destroys
her relationship with not only her lover
but also her family addicts often
express regret at how they have treated
others when under the influence and
drugs and alcohol are often cited as the
reason for several breakups and
estranged family relationships there are
also several other allusions in the form
of le self harming and going through the
rubbish looking for a hit meth addicts
are often attributed as having picked at
their face until there are deep scabs
and cuts due to the drugs effect on them
and I have seen several addiction
documentaries that often focus on people
rooting through rubbish in order to
secure something that can provide
another hit similar to the way that most
addicts feel led using itself as a curse
upon a family and things that
would be better off without her this is
often a tragic symptom of mental illness
and addiction and one of the huge
negatives of drugs that causes suffering
in the long-term overall I thought
family blood did an admirable job at
tackling some of the more way he themes
that exists today however the film was
poorly paced and in my eyes the overall
execution left of feeling Hollow this is
a shame as there's a wealth of
discussion to be had on the film
thematically but it just doesn't seem to
nail down its points in a way that would
provide an interesting analysis as
always I'd love to hear your thoughts on
the film so if you've seen it please
comment below discussing your takeaways
from it if you're struggling with
addiction then I highly recommend
checking out mind they deal heavily with
addiction and dependency and are always
willing to help those who want to turn
their life around if you enjoyed this
video please like it and subscribe to my
channel I do ending explain videos
across a wide range of media from films
to games and TV I recently discussed the
ending of God of War and infinity war so
make sure you check out those next
thanks very much for taking the time to
watch this I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]